part history mostly legend and 100%
drama Vikings has given fans six whole
seasons of fighting and feuding but the
series actually lost one of its most
deliciously cunning characters way back
in season four Alisa Sutherlands I'll
slog made a memorable entrance in
Vikings at the end of season 1 and the
start of season 2 a princess of yacht
island owl slug was the orphaned
daughter of a dragon slaying father and
the warrior mother she also claimed to
be a woman who had visions of the future
but her preferred battlefield was the
bedroom owl slugs started by seducing
farmer turned warrior and future King
Ragnar with her wit hence a potential to
bear him his prophesize sons Ragnar wife
lagertha meanwhile was less than
impressed with our slog and the two
woman's rocky relationship through the
next few seasons of Vikings finally
culminated in laga first shooting
arrival in the back it wasn't doubtedly
a dramatic death especially as it looked
for a minutes like owl slug might
actually escaped with her life but what
was that moment the right time to say
goodbye to such a deviously fun
character well barring her character's
gift of foresight Sutherland actually
saw her Vikings exit coming in 2016
right after our slogs final episode
aired the actress told Entertainment
Weekly that she had been waiting for al
slug to be killed off ever since she
joined the show she admitted the whole
time I was on Vikings I was waiting for
this to happen I figured because my
character have been introduced in such a
controversial way the only thing to do
with there was to get rid of her at some
points I actually thought it would
happen earlier to be honest she went on
to explain that she found out for sure
that our slug was going to die during
season 4 while they were filming
episodes 9 and 10 one of the producers
approached her while she was waiting to
film a scene and she choked up being
approached in that manner must have
meant a character was about to die
that's exactly what was happening as it
turns out both Sutherland said she
accepted our slogs fate because the
characters manner of death fits her
personality of course you could argue
that like 1/3 gets the final word in the
ongoing feud but Sutherland believes our
slug goaded her rival into giving her a
send-off fit for a Viking
she told aw I think that's a Viking way
of being killed if she just went walking
off somewhere else what was she going to
do die of old age that's not a very
dramatic death for her the Vikings
believed in dying in battle being famous
all you do is hope for it to be really
dramatic
I think else log1 said the same thing
it is the God sort of woven our
destinies not ourselves this plus move
wasn't just about Al's log either after
four seasons anchored around Fillmore's
King Ragnar Vikings crater Michael
Hearst felt that it was time to move on
and tell the stories of the next
generation this was an especially juicy
prospect for a storyteller because some
of these tales and characters were
actually more famous today than those of
Ragnar thus the reason
Travis film or left Vikings after season
four and why his carrots emetic grizzly
snake-filled ends on the episode after
al slogs death Hearst had always seen
the story of Vikings as being a
generational spanning saga in fact
Ragnar wasn't even supposed to make it
out of the first season that was when
king eller was supposed to get exact
serpent time vengeance on Ragnar for
killing his brother aethelwulf
unfortunately for the show audiences
didn't form the same attachment to
Ragnar's now adult sons it didn't help
that all have been children until the
Showtime jumped six years forward midway
through an episode during season 4 which
may help to explain why Vikings as
ending with season six
but don't worry Vikings fans because
things don't end there there's a spinoff
series in the works over at Netflix
titled Vikings Valhalla which is due for
release in 2021 check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite shows
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]